this weekend on history bookshelf author
James Chase talks about his book 1912
Wilson Roosevelt Taft and Debs
the election that changed the country
professor chase describes the
personalities or relationships between
Woodrow Wilson Theodore Roosevelt
William Howard Taft and Eugene Debs and
welcome to viewers on c-span's book TV
today we're here to discuss James
Chase's new book 1912 Wilson Roosevelt
Taft and Debs the election that changed
the country which has just been
published by Simon & Schuster Woodrow
Wilson Center is the official memorial
to our 28th President was created in
1968 by an act of Congress within the
Smithsonian Institution because Woodrow
Wilson had at Princeton University
before becoming president the center
memorializes his legacy by serving as a
bridge between the worlds of academia
and public policy the center fulfills
this mission to a residential Fellows
Program and by serving as a neutral
forum for over 400 meetings a year at
which even the most contentious issues
can be discussed the center is not vigus
II it takes no position on policy issues
rather the purpose of this institutions
research and meetings is to contribute
to the policy debate by providing
historical context and an understanding
of foreign cultures and perspectives the
results of these activities are widely
disseminated through reports and books
published by the center's own press
website of Wilson Center org a radio and
TV program called dialogue and the
Wilson quarterly the center's president
is former Indiana congressman Lee
Hamilton as the nation's official
memorial to our 28th president it is
particularly appropriate that we meet
here today to discuss the momentous
election of 1912 that took him to the
White House we are so to speak heavily
invested in that election as that
without it there would be no Woodrow
Wilson Center
James Chase has produced the definitive
study of that election he's the Paul
Williams professor of government
laught Bard College is the former
managing editor of Foreign Affairs
magazine and editor of world policy
journals is the author of eight previous
books including Acheson the secretary of
state who created the American world
which which was named best book of 1998
by the American Academy of diplomacy
high praise for this book has been
offered by former Wilson Center Fellow
and biographer Ronald Steele 1912
relates with Brio high drama and
authority the struggle of four powerful
men fighting not just for the presidency
but for the soul of American politics
James Chase brings vividly to life the
election that shaped the nation's future
and in so doing illuminates the
momentous choices American space then
and face again today James Chase thank
you for being with us today thank you
very much I'm really delighted to be
back here when I was in Washington a
number of years ago I spent a year here
not at the Wilson Center but the
Carnegie Endowment but spent a good deal
of time over here friends who were there
at the time I'm also I suppose we could
call this the accidental presidency but
then it's about four men obviously not
just Woodrow loosen but it is certainly
true that I had the party not been split
by between Taft Ramallah Taft and
Theodore Roosevelt it's very unlikely
that upward rules would have been
elected president almost surely had
Roosevelt government nomination it would
have been Roosevelt was president
however had it been it had it been a
task Wilson thing I think that Wilson
would have won even though the United
States was basically majority party was
a Republican party but it was as we all
know a period of tremendous spirit of
reform and for that and reform was
embraced by Wilson close by Roosevelt
and of course by dead therefore Taft was
rather Mo's a moderate conservative was
not likely I think to have beaten
but those are I think almost surely
wouldn't four and talked about them and
I want to say first of all what why I
wrote the book I say this because people
often asked why writing a book and which
foreign policy plays absolutely no role
when you spent your whole life writing
about foreign policy and the answer is
it was foreign policy that got me
interested in the book in this issue
these issues its counterfactual history
sort of what ifs of history why what
would have happened in other words had
Taylor Rosa Robin Wilson been president
in 1912 well had that happened the
Republican Party would have been the
party of reform and secondly I would
suspect that after the sinking of the
Lusitania in 1915 that Roosevelt would
have brought the United States into the
first world war at that time he was very
very sympathetic the Allies he was not
trying to pursue as Wilson was at that
time a neutralist policy was very Pro
allied in his speeches etc and in these
personal letters and I think he would
have taken advantage of of that
crotchety in fact to get the United
States in World War one of them perhaps
the world might have ended more quickly
had the United States done that it's a
couple of other other what is that like
dimension right at the beginning let's
say Roosevelt had not challenged Taft
for the nomination Republican Party in
1912 tasks I say I think would have been
beaten by Wilson and then but then
Roosevelt would have had the nomination
almost surely in 1916 indeed some of his
closest colleagues told him that that he
could just wait he would have in 1916
era and the likeliest he would have been
elected because the person who ran
against Wilson in 1916 which was 89 in
1916 who was a Charles Evans Hughes over
a moderate reformist governor of New
York State Supreme Court justice that is
it that Hughes all almost won
when when Wilson went to sleep that
night he thought he'd lost the election
to a to Hughes and then when the results
from California came in the next morning
and that was a foot put Wilson over in
1916 and was largely because huge had
alienated members of the Progressive
Party the then Governor of California
man called Hiram Johnson but had he been
had he been paid more attention to
Johnson in the right way but he would
probably take California having taken
California Wilson was not even present
in 1960 and therefore it would not have
been the war president then finally this
very interesting I found out which is it
Roosevelt repaired his relationships
with the Republican Party which is split
in 1912 by 1918 in 1916 campaign for
Jews we never liked your photos as the
old as the iceberg and here but he
featherless radius pieces and campaigned
vigorously for and Roosevelt was nothing
of the US campaigner and he began of
course then he became very critical of
Woodrow Wilson's handling of the war
almost all historians agree that by 1919
Roosevelt was effect would would have
been the nominee of Republican Party in
1920 he died at the age of relatively
young age of 60 in January of 1990 large
I think because he he lived the
strenuous life but but but such a
strenuous life that he hoped died on a
brother got a Brazilian expedition in
1915 so the point is that even in 1920
in other words it is possible that
Roosevelt would have become president
having lived on in which case again the
what instant history in which case would
have been League of Nations with the
large reservations which we weren't very
serious and they would have also been
therefore sightings of the Versailles
Treaty and doubtless a military
guarantee to France which Wilson had
given
and that Rosa vote was very easy to have
it aligns with France and Britain so had
that happened at night has been locked
into the lead but to me much more
important into an actual military
guarantee then one really has to ask
oneself if the German General Staff
would have would have ever risk ever
ever risk of war at that time in the
1930s I know that's these are big
stretches I agree but they do it but as
I get to look at that and I began to
think what what happened why did it
happen what went on and that's what I'm
going to talk about now which is that
election but I'd like to keep in mind as
I said these these were these what ifs
of history
first of all as I said there were four
men and I'm going to talk about
Roosevelt last actually and talk about
each of them so the way then dr. on
together so let me talk about first of
all about William Howard Taft
first of all William Howard Taft came
from the very emotional very
distinguished family in Ohio and was a
great friend it came a great friend of
Theodore Roosevelt the four was ago was
president and then later on cost winning
when Roosevelt became president after
the assassination McKinley in 91 he made
Taft a second secretary Warren
government in junk go to general the
Philippines TAS is an extremely decent
man his politics were moderately
conservative he was not against reform
but is not a person who wanted to rock
the boat too much whereas it arose Lowe
was only too willing to rock the boat
basically Taft was a perfect lieutenant
when Roosevelt announced in nineteen for
that he would not run for third term but
she didn't need to do and which she must
have regretted no sooner were the words
out of his mouth he tried to find
someone who he believed with terrianna
policies were formed in 1980 that he in
started and task seemed him finally the
logical man to do that the staff is a
very able man
Taft himself never wanted to be
president he'd always hoped someday to
be able to Supreme Court but his wife
was a very ambitious woman and she very
much won her husband
president I'm States Christ Taft turned
down offers from from Villa Rosa when
Rose always present to be on Supreme
Court maybe again because his wife
didn't want him to do that but wait and
so finances we all know he he he doesn't
get out of the Supreme Court until much
later we weren't Harding the points of
chief justice Supreme Court which was
the thing that attacked always cared
most about what happened however when
tax was president over simplified
slightly is it he was not able to manage
things the way that Roosevelt was able
to Roseville was very able to handle
these arch conservatives which Taft was
was unable to do so
it was said that Taft is surrounded by
made by men knew exactly what they
wanted to do I guess and that and they
were meant by a by a particularly
powerful thing at senator Nelson Aldrich
of Rhode Island who was called the
manager of the United States so
probability and half couldn't manage a
man achieved well Roosevelt could do
degree and so Roosevelt found that the
policies heater's was simply not being
carried out in the way you hope to but
there's another point too of course
Roosevelt miss power it was only 50 we
left the presidency younger than Bill
Clinton we left and he'd miss that power
what was practicing was referred to as a
head the habit-forming drug of public
life which is public action also missed
by the way the split there for the teen
became very very bitter I'll get into
this a little later but a little more
about him as a person with some brother
abusing stories too first of all as
everybody must know Taft was enormous
I mean he's using we're using 300 and
350 pounds
it was once had to be pried out of a
bathtub and so he had the special
bathtub was put in White House and
another one on a naval ship so he could
do it what he was counter general the
Philippines he wrote his horse about 25
miles up in the hills and then cabled
back to
the Secretary of State le rube that he
never felt better route was spotted very
laconic Li wen how's the horse how's the
hot so so as I say he was a very decent
guy and an able man but not not not some
who should ever the president now let's
go on to Woodrow Wilson Woodrow Wilson
first of all understand Wilson left
understand he was a conservative
southern Democrat born in Virginia grew
up in Georgia and South Carolina he was
a man who began his world who was a
title one person Jamal just give the
basic facts he's been president as you
know the Prince University and then he
was picked by the political bosses of
New Jersey as the perfect person to run
for governor of New Jersey they thought
he was reliable he was really concerned
reasonably conservative Democrat but
he's honest and moderately very
moderately reformist as they saw him
Wilson was therefore elected governor
but then he turned on the bosses and put
through a highly reformist program in
New Jersey they felt completely betrayed
right and as a consequence he became one
of the most likely candidates for the
nomination of the Republican Party in
1912 because he then had had adopted in
adopted reform form as his as his
platform during that during that period
and but his reforms were not as radical
as Roosevelt was more so than Wilson and
after an incredibly tense convention
which went to 46 ballots in Baltimore
where at one point he would do his name
thinking he would not get the nomination
to mentor to champ Clark who had been
the the Speaker of the House and was
really favored to get the nomination he
finally secured it from the machinations
of that old Democratic warhorse William
William Jennings Bryan who was trying to
get it for himself again and if I could
play this was going to be four
a trap clock and then he switched to one
of the trade Wilson and then finally
state this but various reasons he
supported Wilson so ironically Wilson
did get the nomination precisely because
the party bosses wanted him at the lab
of the lab last night so it's an irony
there and then get another talk about
him as a person now
his father was was it was a preacher a
Presbyterian and a man whom Wilson
really adored and also felt deeply
inferior to the father often humiliated
Wilson Wilson could never please him
enough i willfully suffered from
dyslexia he he was very insecure had
terrible headaches
and said he would never really measured
up to what his father expected of him
he was when I used to practice speaking
however and because that's a guess
initially throw him so he might take it
become a Presbyterian minister himself
he he finally decided after graduating
from from Princeton he he became a
professor facto at Bryn Mawr was the
important area to Princeton but it
always wanted to go into politics she
was a very slow reader publishing his
own dyslexic couldn't read very well at
one point he said advocated possibly she
had read a book in ten years serious
book in ten years Luther he was he had a
good few slow and I wanted to slow and
deliberate the very very stubborn man
and he did not like to be criticized and
he broke with his friends we did so in
the foot that was another part of his
Chris presidency Princeton began to have
various reforms he put in the tutorial
system precept toriel system is called
in Princeton and he had a good - good I
think two very good ideas one he wanted
to break the club system of Princeton
which I was a good idea but he didn't
handle it well and the Alumni stopped in
cold
yeah he also wanted to keep the grab
Brooks erect a new graduate school right
near the college and again and he didn't
handle well at all within the faculty
they wanted off on a golf course at
Wilson law so by the time his 1910 came
along he was not a successful present
Prince and he had the opposite effect
what was begun very well that table
words for him and so he was only too
eager to try to run for governor when he
was approached by the by the New Jersey
bosses he was also by the way early this
time a southern white supremacist and he
allowed the resegregate in Washington of
the federal of the federal bureaucracy
it wasn't the polite as gonna call
polite there was it was it was Roger
place against American blacks at that
time by novice but the case of Wilson
was it was it was much deeper he admired
enormous latest will be by DW Griffith's
full force as he said it was a Roberta
nation which is Malo things very racist
film calling a history written with
lightning his he hair he had and he was
a man who could be quite well monk
monkey be so secure with he was very
funny could be very very charming like
women a great deal of and had his
daughters who this is two eyes and
actually an illicit affair which which
did come just did come which was which
came to light later in the election of
1912 to Roosevelt's attention but
Roosevelt refused to make that an issue
in the campaign he said no one could
believe that the banner looks like an
apothecary
could possibly here could possibly be a
Romeo so he whatever the reason was
however he didn't he didn't do that and
the SEPA something Roosevelt would do is
rather puritanical man himself actually
rather Victorian but as you all know it
was losing stubbornness that made it so
difficult in negotiating with a creme on
self educated clever and so in the
British Prime Minister Lloyd George at
Versailles afterward 1930 1919 and then
trying to put together their side treaty
he often felt himself musical the
personal instrument of God
in contrast to that by the way Lloyd
George remarked at the peace conference
I think I did pretty well my didn't buy
pretty well as must be expected seeing
as I was between Jesus Christ and
Napoleon Bonaparte
that was that was more than Georgians
before what it was like between goals
for the club also he refused to
compromises as loose as I said earlier
with a sent over some relatively small
reservations that TR really close his
friend and we kind of Senate Dems Senate
Majority Henry Cabot Lodge insisted on
they were not that serious reservations
they were really mostly reiterating the
fact that the Senate has the after
declared war and the one else has a
right to do so as the responsibility
between it was something which was was
really not not very serious was just a
set of imprimatur but which was used to
compromise whatsoever saying notably the
Senate must take its medicine well that
was our wise thing to say they do when
the Senate and items were controlled by
the by the Republican Party by 19 at the
1918 elections but uh to get the to get
the pre passed he without a barnstorming
tour throughout the country and it was
during that tour September 28 1919 that
he had a severe stroke Colorado on
September 10 on September 28 and he was
not seen by anybody into the end of
October as many of you know us brought
back here in the White House and there
he later he was really quite
incapacitated the first few weeks of the
stroke he finally didn't make it more
than a partial recoveries but never a
full recovery and during the first stage
of that illness he saw nobody but his
wife and his doctor
private doctor dr. Grayson when people
were admitted he was propped up and bent
his body was covered except for his
head's right on the curtains were drawn
very dimly lit when several wanted to
consult her husband's over a matter of
state this is Wilson took the message
and reported back when her husband had
presumably said and sometimes she
answered with a handwritten note a
number of letters went on opened
eventually he recovered enough to talks
I say then take quiet automobile
but in a way his rigidity grew The
Strokes is personal rigidity and when he
left office you know he lived here on
Washington on s Street he died 1924
where he's buried as a National
Cathedral the third manager Jean Deb's
was an extraordinary figure in American
history certainly in American labor
history he grew up and he grew up in
Terre Haute Indiana worked on the
railroads of fireman there was a
decently well educated man you read
French and German his parents came from
al-fath and they were well educated
people eventually joined the Socialist
Party the greatness of Deb's my view lay
in the fact that he never lost sight of
the goal of what we what was we could
call industrial unionism the only
powerful organization with Deb's was a
rock a maram was the American Federation
of Labor which is a craft Union you had
to be a skilled worker with a skilled
craft to be in that union the ordinary
understood worker was excluded from the
Union when Deb saw was needed the
broad-based unionism a unionism with
skilled craftsmen we joined the other
school craftsmen the one great strong
union throughout all of this period he
was a dominant figure in the Socialist
Party of organized labor and in the
election of 1912 when he got the highest
percentage per vote the social spot has
ever gotten in this country is really
apex of its of the Socialist Party
America we got almost a million votes
and in the way the legacy of Deb's
always really the CIO Congress when the
Kaiser industrialization that really had
the kind of broad-based industrial uses
which Deb's felt was necessary to combat
the evils of industrial capitalism which
would grow up across in the late 19th
century again a few things personally
about Deb's
he was a man who would go off on a
speaking tour and literally give
everything you might have to people
returned who needed money returned back
home dead broke he was in prison twice
the first time in 1894 when he led the
strike against the Pullman sleeping car
company
nothing like the problem strike that
have been seen in this country more than
a hundred thousand men could work and
the strike was finally broken federal
troops who said that the behest of the
Democratic president at the time Grover
Cleveland in jail was that dense became
the socialist and also a national
celebrity the reason we ran again and
again for the presidency of the
Socialist Party three or four times
because he was so really why he was
spectating very widely respected
throughout the country was a national
figure in 1920 when he was in jail on
prison two-layer he he ran for
presidency from 1912 but almost got to
being votes again he was the other side
of that the first time this deal was of
the Pullman Strike the second time I was
jailed by a federal court in 1918 for
speaking out against the first world war
under the provision of the new espionage
law and the new sedition of the Sedition
Act although many prominent citizens
brought in different mothers who were
not socialists petition was Wilson would
also give him a pardon Wilson said
deficits a traitor to his country would
never be pardoned during his
administration it was Warren Harding
interesting enough in 1921 release stems
from his prison in Georgia asked him to
drop by the White House on his way home
which he did when steps stepped into
Harding's office haunting strode over
shake his hand I've heard so damn much
about Judas to depths but now I'm very
glad to meet you personally only that's
later said that they understood each
other perfectly and I suspect they did
the theater Roosevelt thought the
Republican nomination 1912 basically had
two reasons if one as I said early he
felt the Taft and betrayed his promises
to follow the reformist policies the TR
had begun in his presidency and as I say
he'd miss the other reasons when he
missed power and he was nonetheless able
unable to secure the Republican
nomination despite the fact that he had
won more primaries in Taft including
taking tax home state of Ohio this was
the first pretty much
direct primaries were coming into
becoming more common in the United
States and they say what Rozsival all
but swept them his former sonically was
his former Secretary of State le rue was
a chairman of Republican convention and
disqualified eighty of TRS delegates
root believes the party must must be
must be held together this way you could
not have this kind of insurgency and in
fact you know I have the nomination
stolen from you should have had at least
seventy seventy-five of those votes and
that would have probably given in the
nomination if not then on the next round
but undaunted of course he Joey joined
the Progressive Party known in history
the bull moose party this is a party
made up of middle-class reformers
schoolteachers well many intellectuals
some populist a lot of people struggling
supporting women's women's suffrage
municipal reformers were fed up with
bosses of the in the cities and
Roosevelt really became their car their
standard-bearer and his opening speech
the progressives he'd acclaim
very famously we stand at Armageddon to
do battle for the Lord it was probably
the most dynamic campaign in American
history TR was a man who grew in office
with his president from 1999 he changed
in many respects okay the time he came
in he would be I would describe as a
patrician reformer but as I say he
didn't police commissioner in New York
City the government New York State and
always wanted to curb the excesses of
the great trusts what he called those
malefactors of great wealth by
regulating them not destroying them as
he believed that big business was here
to stay what he wanted to do is have
people rise above their own sectarian
interests of course he was and been an
imperialist and was imperiously in first
became president the spanish-american
war which he resigned from being
assistant secretary of the Navy in order
to get into the war then led led a group
of combination of Ivy League graduates
and west Wild West Cowboys as the Rough
Riders
and storm San Juan Hill and one at one
of the skirmish against the Spanish but
it made him again a national a national
figure and prepared the way for him
ultimately to get the AA nomination for
vice president the New York public buys
only too willing to get rid of Rosalie's
he's a reformer they didn't wanting
around and they've got what better place
to get rid of than into the vice
presidency when of course McKinley was
assassinated famously mark Hannity the
boss of the Republican Party said now
we've got that damn cowboy in the White
House it was the last thing they ever
expected what happened he was by Steve
Lee the the British ambassador one set
of TR but he was always you must
remember he was always a six year old
boy there's a lot of that in Roosevelt
he was it was surely the most
intellectual president we had since the
founders on his expedition issued wild
beasts in Africa 19:9 but the presidency
he tooks 80 books willing to read his
energy was awesome he would read am
literally a book a day
so we're also writing writing constant
letters and letters potatoes amazing
nothing so many of them but they're so
lengthy and so well written and this is
damn that it's out there that anyone
would quite that energy there's also
very much a family man and and you'd
like to have Z called a romp of the boys
the boys before boys care to Archie
tournament and Quentin all the boys
served in the First World War and the
definitely Edna's boy Quentin who said
before when Laurie joined the Air Force
that we got to practice with Tom
preaches was shot down over Germany
through the terrible blow firm which
really deeply shadows his last days and
one daughter was the outspoken Alice of
shop tons of Alice Longworth and whom he
could never control as he said when
someone complained about Alice's
outrageous behind it so I can be present
or I can try to control hours I can't do
both she was the offspring of t-ara T's
first life Alex Lee you die
a few years after their marriage on the
same day as his mother
if second marriage Edith Carroll was a
happy one
either through the door ting since
childhood understood the need to tone
down his boorish behavior but also
understood and supported his need for
venture the rough housing days with
cowboys and trappers his safari in
Africa it is all the fatal exploration
of the river of doubt in Brazil after he
lost election 1912 one more anecdote
about Roosevelt got about that I could
tell us about how perhaps the most
famous example of his energy occurred
during the 1912 campaign this was after
a period when it was before television
and radio and so of course you had to
speak for hours at a time all ratios
were meant to be a long time people came
out in droves to see the candidates they
expect to be entertained and it was also
beginning of the sort of whistles
stopping campaign from the back of back
of the railroad cars went from town to
town and the two most gifted artists
were actually Deb's and Roosevelt Wilson
also spoke beautifully but he didn't but
it was not as energetic as the other two
though they were stem winders in that
sense this was an elegant elegant
speaker but not a stem wanted in the
late stage of the campaign in October
when Roosevelt was campaigning the
middle West man came out of a hotel and
as roseville got into the car and picked
up a gun and shot was shot a moonshot
Rozsival I'm Roosevelt's life was only
saved because he had a 50-page speech
put inside his pocket here he was
bleeding and and nonetheless he insisted
on going on to make the speech he was
supposed to make it was of course
against the advice of these doctors he
says going to do it no one could stop
Roosevelt and when he got up on a
platform for about 10,000 people
he opened his coat and you can see the
blood you know on the thing and said you
know it takes more than one bullet to
kill a bull moose and then and then it
spoke that for 45 minutes finally then
went off to a hospital
whereas the next two weeks and then
Wilson and dead and Taft all stop
campaigning while he while he recovered
now what was the importance of the
election of 1912 well I think first of
all it introduced the conflict between
what we called progressive idealism and
conservative values and this struggle I
think dominates the politics of the 20th
century soon I became the pot apostle
really of progressive idealism what he
called the new nationalism what you
described is using executive power as a
steward of public welfare
in other words removal came as president
he knew he couldn't get certain things
passed by Congress and Congress between
roughly the end of the Civil War from
Lincoln after Lincoln to Roosevelt was
was fast folks was far stronger than the
presidency that the executive branch and
the most presence believe that Congress
should propose and they were disposed
but they were not as strong at all oh
how did you get around this well
Roosevelt really used executive orders
as much as possible executive action
agreements which could be done which the
Congress didn't have to vote on much of
the millions of acres which Roosevelt
saved for conservation purposes we're
not going to get that passed by Congress
they were done for executive agreements
by 1912 though he had become far more
radical and he called the platform was
many ways the most radical platform that
any presidential candidate has ever ever
stood for sonoran he called for women's
suffrage graduated income tax
inheritance tax comprehensive workmen's
compensation Act prohibition of child
labor downward revision the tariffs in
an interstate commerce commission that
supervised all corporations engaged in
interstate business and even national
health care the full civil of promise of
American life which was a book written
by Herbert Crowley which was the was a
model for what we thought the leader
should be like kion believed that the
country needed what he called
Hamiltonian means to achieve
Jeffersonian
in other words he he thought the
Jeffersonians error was not their
devotion to equality but their inability
to see the degree to which they were
sacrificing a desirable Liberty to an
undesirable equality Jefferson believed
that they should be as little government
as possible and the good things of life
which have already been held by the few
were now to be distributed among all the
people Allison while too eager perhaps
to attach to the government the
supportable of the well-to-do bleep
rumor is that well to do with elites we
rescue to run the country but
nonetheless in many ways more clear
thinking the Jefferson he knew the
genuine Liberty could be protected only
by the energetic and clear-sighted
central government and it was that idea
of the central government energy and the
executive to accomplish these things
that does Hamiltonian means for
Jeffersonian aims of course in another
way and rancheros new biocad Hampton is
very very good reading bunch on how that
happened and really saw the future
United States far more clearly also can
jettison it became what Hamilton thought
it might industrial and urban financial
Joe Wilson in his campaign in his
camping Wilson echo the need to restore
competition as the best way of
destroying the trucks and he was
influenced in speaking by Louis Brandeis
who that time as a brilliant lawyer in
Boston by a Louisville and of course
Lane reported by Wilson to the Supreme
Court destroying monopolies was the best
way to restore a competition and he
called this the new freedom as Wilson
put it what is create what has created
these monopolies unregulated competition
ultimately if I hope to appeal to Diaz
constituency without offending the
states rights traditions the Democratic
Party's white selling base depth of
course invade against those would
mistake reform for revolution he wanted
the state of course to have basic
ownership of the monopolies that he
believed controlled the American working
people this utopian program however also
included reform legislation which TR and
then later was the doctor at one point
have said my god they're taking they're
taking my platform away from me and to a
certain degree they did a tax
conservatism he saw reform as embedded
in the law corporations that violated
law should be prosecuted and have bought
more suits against the trust and trt
during his term in office but can't also
believe that the progressive project
would stimulate unfulfillable
expectations
TAF seizure Republican nomination 1912
produce such a deep split in the
Republican Party has never been healed
to this very day t oz reform is in a way
represents a road not taken' Wilson his
first term having adopted his
performance part policies was able to
pass more progressive legislation than
any other president except for Franklin
Roosevelt in the New Deal encouraged by
a Democratic Congress Wilson reduced
tariffs achieved the passage of a
graduated income tax federal established
the Federal Trade Commission which
intensified regulation of business the
Clayton Antitrust Act which which was
more you know what you think put forth
further antitrust measures for miss
Sherman earlier Sherman Act Ardell 1890
the popular lecture of us 7 and that's
most important of all the Federal
Reserve Act would perform the banking
system by creating a european-style
central bank that would monitor the
nation's money supply as we know and
smooth out these dangerous fluctuations
mainly what it meant that no longer
private bankers like JP Morgan run the
monetary policy United States which is
exactly what he did a few years earlier
Tiana's and Wilson's approaches
regulation or competition are still in
my view the central issues of how
government should promote the commerce
and welfare of the American people and
the task Roosevelt argument over the
role of executive limited and tax our
approach expansive in TR and later
Wilson's you as well despite the talk of
small business and states rights
Wilson factors also is very strong
executive
they've been together they tapped and
attached seized me TR and Wilson really
invented the modern purr
their legacy was really to believe that
a centralized power would create a
stronger democracy and TR therefore I
Mattie I should say and Franklin Delano
Roosevelt was their greatest inherent in
that respect in foreign policy Franklin
D our four heroes will also learn from
both of them he became what he called a
practical idealist best combined in my
view the rule the realism of TR with the
idealism of Woodrow Wilson asked for
tasks and Theodore Roosevelt their
splendid friendship was repaired before
TR died and the last man to leave
Roosevelt's graveside after his funeral
was William Howard Taft we be thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much James we have some
time for some comments and questions
from the floor after the session the
book will be available for purchase and
employee we have a reception as well but
we have some time for comments on the
floor who would like to be addressing
and we have a microphone for you thank
you actually struggled for the
Republican nomination in 1912 no
incumbent Republican present president
who sought reen AMA nation was denied it
had been denied it by his party in 28
years and how realistic knowing
especially that you had delegates from
southern states they know which the
Republican Party could not carry but
were wholly dependent on patronage and
therefore not in play was it ever a
realistic hope on Theodore Roosevelt's
part that he could actually wrest the
nomination from the Republican
afterthought it initially Roosevelt
actually was not was quite pessimistic
about getting getting the president he
was not it was he was that he felt he
had to do it he felt this because of the
cloak or betrayal he felt of the reform
policies but
but as time went on of course he began
to believe that he might get it part of
the difference really was about the
primary system the fact is that the
direct primaries were coming into into
into for and and Roosevelt began wearing
on or not almost them and therefore when
he came to the convention he
theoretically had enough delegates to
get that nomination over violence but
what he didn't Bank on was that the very
party machine he had set up you see
Roosevelt was extremely able politician
just about this this word 1912 makes it
big making seem someone who was
unrealistic about on the contrary was
extremely able politician and he'd say
hehehe or he made a bargain party even
in more powerful in terms of his
organization and turned that very
authorization across over the Taft that
was the organization in the long run
stood against him and disqualified these
delegates and it wasn't it wasn't he
said it was stolen stolen nomination of
was so the answer is yes or no because
in one way yes he should happen but
departing chains too strong that bands
out just what you see which is believed
that they were they were like the one to
deny it to him for that reason is
burger with the Woodrow Wilson Center
during the campaign you mentioned that
Roosevelt platform in 1912 did support a
women's suffrage I know
Wilson stood against it but in reading
some of the materials during that period
I saw one speech he was giving on the
trust and and a woman got up and said
what about the suffrage and then Wilson
said that my subject is the monopolies
and she said so it's mine and that's
about you know all did he in any way
justify you know his opposition to
women's suffrage and also what was a tax
position on on that issue during the
campaign well you know it's a enough of
a suffrage issue all of and I would and
that one would probably include tad to
Deb's to certain degree and would have
included Roosevelt Missouri when that
just felt that the country wasn't ready
for this kind of thing you're probably
and and and and we took very traditional
back to that period view of the wife's
role so I don't think it was any field
we're not ready for again I'm not quite
here then something that is it Roosevelt
changed as I said he changed became more
and what's interesting is how radically
did become accurate left office he
wasn't big service but by the time 1912
company but he had embraced it and the
person one the prisoners under who were
seconded his nomination present second
his nomination to progressive convention
was Jane Addams who was perhaps the
leading suffragette of that period so he
he had changed the same thing towards up
towards of blacks American blacks now
the Roosevelt had invited Booker T
Washington for dinner at the White House
shortly after came president well that
causes scandal and the South never
forgave him for that
and he never invited him back to the
White House itself even though so he had
he had a complicated problem there for
1912 because he had P because he had
become much more supportive of what
we've gotten called civil rights for
blacks particularly getting rid of Jim
Crow laws
and the polar taxes effectively
prevented them from voting in the south
but he at the same time he wanted to get
try to get the Republican Party have son
to get some white voters out of the
south so he straddled to a certain
degree 1912 his relations I'll be being
a embracing embracing American blacks
openly and yet yet yet he dined with
them different times in New Jersey and
other parts of London she was in Rhode
Island another part of the country
he had also when he was president
appointed many them into fed into a jobs
in the government federal that would
rather got many federal jobs for them
but he had to describe lacrosse was a
big mistake they didn't get anywhere
that the Republic got nowhere in the
south of 1912 but it's interesting
because he he was he was freed in some
ways realizing mistake he made and
therefore was much more openly
supportive of organ call civil rights
for another black when he was he was
very thickened and died as I said in
January of 1919 he deep he'd been
hospital in December and the last speech
he made was it was in late December on
for 1918 s or we could do her I died it
wasn't very well but got off a
nevertheless made his speech in the New
York City for the most radical of all
blackness was wvb to voice last public
speech type of theorems ever made so he
was interesting he grew he grew Taft
attacked avi was fairly conventional
about Selfridge himself but liked it
like a little and the early the early
Roosevelt
I'd like to ask a question about about
debts and socialism he openly campaign
as a socialist the word socialism has
become such a dirty word in American
politics is that a trivial only the
Bolshevik Revolution or was it a dirty
word back in 1912 as well well it's
always a genuine joy depending on where
you kinda where you stood so to speak
but I would say that certainly the
motion remember we should change it go
to Z and it spent the Socialist Party a
lot to were the units in supporting it
he was a socialist he but he was not how
to put it the Socialist Party was riven
by by by theological I'd almost call
them casuist exploits between more
conservative socialists who said we we
should we should we should we should
cooperate with reformers the people in
far more revolutionary like the big bill
Haywood of the mess and Deb's wasn't he
he didn't why he was not good at all at
nor did he care much for for all these
intellectual discussions which were
really became quite bitter not and and
saw himself as above these despair
trying to unify the fight always trying
to appeal he always kept his eye on on a
union on the Union and he wasn't dead of
unionism and he often identified it with
the American Revolution his gravy is
basically by the many members most was
not Karl Marx but Abraham Lincoln I mean
and vote Lincoln and he and also
Washington so that he was a he tied it
to the revolutionary tradition of the
United States so they sitting socials
were quite popular although this is a
period of enormous reform and and of
course as we all know rampant capitalism
which was brutally treated workers
there's no question about it the late
19th century 20 century so the Socialist
Party was was was you know battle a lot
of support quite frankly it was really
not until later first of all a lot of
the reforms were taken over by TR and
Wilson and then the party lost support
during the war because the social I
oppose the war but many individual
social systems
so that's pretty much all I can say
there well thank you very much James
Chase for visiting the Woodrow Wilson
Center today to discuss here in a book
1912 this pivotal pivotal election
please join me in thanking game stage
for the presentation
[Applause]
and there's a reception and the
opportunity to purchase the book and a
play thank you